yes of course
so else is a tactical JRPG old-school
thanks very much in the style of Final
Fantasy Tactics did you say Final
Fantasy Tactics so tactics order all
these other types of games that used to
be very popular a while ago and we feel
like that market that's kind of what mr.
Lee died down with the fans have not
made so what we got here is a story
[Music]
[Music]
the gameplay as well
but our game
everything's into the
although if you look at the maths you
might understand
[Music]
you know everything terrain but the
master actually took me
[Music]
the one visit
but the upside is that we get this very
unique different art style which
absolutely beginning of the game
so basically your character isn't
arbiter and the our leaders are busy in
first
[Music]
[Applause]
water random
figure out what's happening
thirty hours it can't be like sometimes
it in oder games like this it was easier
to fight the more accurate though not
all encounters will again there's
diverse them like objectives some of
them are like you need to clear the map
some of them are defending
and some of them are just you know you
get though the main bad guy is over
there's a we're trying to keep it in
French
different naps
ha
so we have a bit of everything so when
you start the game there
six story characters but just like
school games we can recruit
we connected
and there something there we know the
customers
that's unique I've never seen
and all these and I've played a lottery
what do you think got me into the XCOM
series it was this yeah
that person of connection
No
fitting that I like
and that's second yeah there's a loss to
me to the portrait you have and
oh that's not like
PlayStation thanks
we said we're hoping to get their mom
but in its it's the only platform that
we're not guaranteed yet but we're very
awful
in industry
oh yes Scotty the reef
so there's a lot more classes
20 base classes but you have to love one
up like the black ones are classes that
you know about because you are
you know the requirements where you have
not met them yet a great one is a
classic you know about because someone
else has cemented their requirement in
your team but you personally am so
pretty much the black ones and stuff you
encountered on the actual battlefield
you can I mean all classes are
accountable there's a lot of monsters
they're not into
but we have 13 different
having multiple
there's bosses buzz
otherwise you are the visit for your old
lady writer students
but they have a wide range of
so the crafting system is fairly simple
you gather some components
special badges that give access to
secret class
and I'll sir your item sarcastic so
never buy items but the advantage is
that every battle
you can always use them
you don't have to hoard them and see
so did the traffic tags into that
covered items in the
it works a lot like the palm Fantasy
Tactics advance for you can that's how
you upgrade your it's exactly pain yes
alright again fell sale we're looking at
a release off if you ladie one early q2
2004 2019 on their coming coming so long
mister work most of the engines are
created right now we're just adding
story and content just adding the maps
as soon as we go generate them so and
I'd say right now there's a solid fifty
percent in their program we're looking
forward to event and also hopefully on
the Nintendo slips absolutely very much